[Music]
so Jamie welcome and thank you very much
for coming here today
pleasure to be here thank you everybody
notice a lot of other folks y'all didn't
expect to be here so welcome friends
from other places so this is the third
time you've come to talk to us and I
have to ask are we just very lucky to
have you or is there some perhaps some
latent regret in choosing our competitor
on the East Coast if you're in business
school so why my wife went to Harvard
Business School I was a hard business
goal my daughter went to hard Bisco and
two summer laws weren't to Harvard
Business School but we love Stanford
like like to come out here all the time
and I come in here I realized why you
don't work so hard out here now speaking
of Business School we have many people
in the room who are trying to decide
between entrepreneurship and more
traditional paths I'm leaving do you
mind talking to the decision you made on
leaving Harvard yourself and if you do
the same thing today so I when I I'd
worked at a small really second-rate
consulting company before business go
back then they had to thing called defer
to MIT so I'd admitted by had to work
for two years and I thought it and you
know I did the consulting thing you
learn a lot I also learned that even
want to be a consultant and and by well
I saw a whole bunch of different
companies and industries and including
badly run political all these various
things so it was actually a very good
experience but I got when I got to
Harvard Business School I actually
worked at Goldman Sachs the summer of 81
and I was headed back to Goldman Morgan
Lehman as plugins I Goldman and the last
minute Sandy Weill offered me this job
to be his assistant you just old
Shearson which is a brokerage firm with
her a couple thousand brokers to
American Express and it just it looked
like it was just too good to not to see
a large corporation for the inside how
it goes my goal in life was to you know
be poor of an organization it wasn't
necessary to be an investment banker or
a trade or something like that so I took
the crapshoot I figured worst comes to
worst I can go back to Wall Street so I
didn't feel like I was you know they
lose anything but time yeah well yes I'd
make the same decision again maybe not
for the same guy again but the same
decision
now sunny oil obviously saw something in
you at the time when you meet men and
women our age at JPMorgan today what
leadership characteristics are you
looking for in them and how do you
identify and bring those people through
as the next generation well when you're
young it's hard to say leadership
characteristics but uh so I mean there's
just some basic stuff you know they're
people who know a lot you know so
there's some people walk into your
office and say yeah I'd like to know
about the strategy of the company and
they didn't bother to read the
Chairman's letter I wrote which is like
30 or 40 pages along there people walk
in and say you know you really should be
thinking about doing better digital
services but didn't look at the ones we
do do they're the other people walk in
and they know everything and so they
have a conversation they're actually
enhancing your life as opposed to the
way around so you know character is a is
a scenic wonton and by character I also
mean that they tell the whole truth
nothing but the truth
they don't shave the truth and they say
the same thing to you that they say to
you because the second I see people
doing something different than that you
just go on a list to me I have no
interest I don't have time for that and
I don't have any said so and people who
are good you know relate well they're
people so um so a variety of things and
I think when we when we look at finance
ears often people concentrate on the
competitive leadership characteristics
they see they're at the GSB we have a
real focus on the collaborative how do
you see the balance between competitive
and collaborative creative inside a
company inside now look I think the
things that destroy companies folks or
bureaucracy and politics and you know so
and you know I we had an off-site this
summer I'd I was asking many times I can
you know we got to make this simpler we
gotta make this better you know we got
to kill our meetings are too long and we
stand behind regulations sometimes a
regular than they go to do it but I said
no we're gonna reimagine all these
things the way they should be not the
way they are today and let's take a
crack at killing some of those
bureaucracies growing up recently and
wrote a memo for and we all do pre reads
and my meetings you don't flip through a
chart it's all three reads I expect you
to do your homework get the analysis and
and parted up with people beforehand so
you don't walk in and say why I want to
do a B and C if I haven't spoken this
person yet I would say why do you speak
this person the mean is cancelled go do
that first and then come back with a
joint recommendation or you disagree and
then we'll talk about was specifically
why you disagree about
anyway I'd ask about bureaucracy the
pre-read started by saying bureaucracy
is a necessary condition an output of
complex businesses operating compatible
environments it's just not true okay
Braco C kills bureaucracy drives out
good people drives an innovation it
makes the person the office next to you
a competitor and not a collaborator and
that's a really bad idea inside a
company you know it's okay to compete
with ideas but it's a really bad idea
where you're competing with the person
next to you it creates politics and if
you look at what skilled companies over
the years it was bureaucracy and if you
look at the fortune you know five
hundred and you did a 1950 1960 97 98
look at the companies who failed it was
because they were dumb bureaucratic
backward and political and CEO should
never allow that stuff and yet they do I
mean it's a normal course they allow it
and you've seen a lot of public
companies and boards allow boards can
create it by the way so so yeah absolute
collaboration but collaboration does not
mean everyone has to agree collaboration
does not mean you go along to get along
because that's a very well thought
people mean by it and he's a good guy
and basically just you know if you walk
into me and say I'm gonna be loyal to
you I would question what that means
because you should be loyal to the
institution you should be lower the
customers you could be loyal to the
principles which I stand but being loyal
to me usually means going to defend my
decision whether or not you agree and
which I I just think it's a mistake
you're well known for having a very
candid and open forthright style of
communication as appreciated by Warren
Buffett he says he lots of chairman
letters and we obviously appreciate it
here what was it that led you to develop
this style of communication early on
well I'm one of those who I don't think
I've changed much since I've been eight
and you know when I got to when I got to
Harvard Business girls let me advice I
got when I was graduating was whatever
you do Jamie don't go into corporate
America you won't survive and I
obviously and by that there was truth to
that you know he was a little too
outspoken and you know for some
corporations etc and I you know part of
it was Warren Buffett so I read when I
was in high school or college I actually
read his partnership letters and they
were and he would say I'll speak to you
as if you're my smart sister who doesn't
know everything I know so I have to go
out of my way to explain it to you and
you know business is not
complicated we should explain it so I
always felt exactly the same way I
always felt as a matter of principle
inside a company if I allow spinning to
the public
you are gonna spin to me and think of
you know earnings numbers and how great
we're doing we're not and so I say the
same thing to you that I say to my board
they say to my shareholders I say to my
employee they say to my customer there
is no difference
I might phrase it differently to talking
to difficult people and trying to
explain yourself but there is no
difference and that that clarity I think
helps a company know was trying to
accomplish all the time and you know I'm
when I read annual letters it sold
gobbly [ __ ] in the lottery I my respects
that can be dropped a little bit you
know and and and then you got to be very
specific because we can all say well the
customer is the most important thing and
the customer the customer nobody you
know what it should mean it should mean
something specific like do you actually
read customer complaints and then you do
something about it as opposed to we put
the customer first a lot of people say
that and they don't mean it in any way
shape or form they do no actions it
would actually support the statement so
this one I'm afraid I'm gonna try and
sneak in some old career advice I think
everyone here is aware that tech is
extremely sexy right now what do you
think is the a little bit less so today
what I said today what do you think is
the opportunity in a career in finance
that someone in the audience may be on
seeing so you know first of all the one
thing about tech tech has driven I don't
think it's different than it was before
it's driven change throughout all of
history you know and it's an all various
forms of Technology from the actual you
know from chips to internet but also you
know printing you know energy
institutions you know schools the
churches the dissemination of morality
and that's what's always change society
and you know and it's always at the root
is that the root of changes in
businesses as the root of changes and
you know what companies do well with
companies don't do well so it is
absolutely critical
I personally in Silicon Valley kind of
got a free ride with Obama and the White
House you know they they they pandered
you panted to him and he pander to you
and now you're seeing a little flip side
of that so the big companies the
successful ones gonna find out which
I've known a long time the big you are
the more the government's gonna get
inside you what you do and want to
impose you on you and set rules and
standards and sometimes for good
sometimes not for good but so financial
services so I think technology
absolutely wonderful thing but financial
services first we are a huge user
technology we spend nine billion dollars
a year so we're you know we're we're not
at the bleeding edge but we're damn
close in terms of what we spend money on
what we do or our data centers our
capabilities are mobile digital moving
and we move six trillion dollars around
the world every day
digitally not crypto currency but close
to it because because it's digital you
know and you know we we banked 50
million people in our households and
soon we're gonna have online built no I
mean online investing and Robo
investment all these various things to
link into our accounts so we are huge
users of that kind of stuff we also
obviously use the advertising of
Facebook and Google Chat or not but
financial services is always going to be
an interesting business because it's
it's not the most important piece but it
is that the nexus of of how a capital
society functions it's part of the spin
wheel and I'm when I say financial
service I'm talking about all of it you
know private equity venture capital
activists whether you like them or not
banks non banks individual investors and
a lot of companies that do things
individually that help change the world
a little bit but that it's always gonna
be this feel that where money gets
invested ideas come together things get
executed capital gets executed globally
so it's always fascinating it'll always
be well-paid whatever you know some of
these folks say in DC it has to be
well-paid but you can't do it you know
with dumb people making dumb decisions
if you think you'd actually run a good
economy or something like that it'd
always be a high tech user and it'll
always be complex and global by its
nature you know and so it's a
fascinating business when you wake up in
the morning but I mean I read the paper
there's very little in the paper that
I'm not reading thing about it affects
our clients it affects our companies it
affects our risk it affects our exposure
we should be doing something about it
like just any article because we do
business and you know well over 100
countries you know and with help just
about every country and every Sun well
fun so it's a fascinating field I mean
when you get into it there are all
different parts to and you got to decide
how you want to if you wanted answer how
you want to get into that one of the
things we set up which I really like is
we hired top-notch people
for Investment Banking okay and sales
and trading so we go to the best schools
in the world we hire some of the best
people we now do the same thing for
general management about eight or nine
or ten a year because we need people who
can run the damn joint - and I want the
same quality and we move around the
company kind of keep an eye on them and
you know but the point is they want to
be global they want to move around and
they want to learn how to manage and run
something so the same kind of
compensation is the best bankers same
openness to senior people so we can get
that done and not that if your
investment Bain you can't move into
management or you know sales and trading
but this is really people want to do
more management financial services so
you you mentioned the cryptocurrency I
know you said you weren't gonna talk
about Bitcoin anymore but you're a
Stanford some of us put all our student
loan money into it and I have to ask you
anyway why do you believe the
governments and regulators can't allow
the existence of a global currency
become like a spokesman against Bitcoin
I don't think I don't care about Bitcoin
I could give us yet to tell you the
truth and I promised myself I wouldn't
talk about the next day I did there are
four things really quickly blockchain is
real its technology it could be public
or private it could be for five people
it could be for a 5 million it's gonna
work when you already use it in a lot of
test cases and stuff like that so we're
a supporter I do worry a little bit
about the security because like I said
we move six trillion dollars a day
real-time quite efficiently effectively
and secure before you replace that you
gotta make sure you can you can do it
right there are three crypto currencies
okay three types three separate types
one is I cos I see oh and I haven't
studied these things but you're paying
for a token that allows you to use a
service which is very different than a
currency but that's what people call
crypto currencies and maybe Jim maybe
you've studied some his eye shows I have
no idea you know about someone give you
cloud services or something you
investing in services that's one type
the second type you can use crypto
currency for fiat currency well that
works because it just used a different
technology to move money around
we don't basically keep your money
digitally anyway and if you just keep
different files in a different way and
distributed Ledger's that would work
fine but I've always thought about
Bitcoin as a currency and a store value
and a payment
in ISM is that governments and this is
my belief and I may be wrong I'm not
saying you can't go to $100,000 that
governments are going to crush it one
day for three reasons
okay one is when it's used for terrorist
activities okay it'll happen
it's matter time you know go back to a
Bitcoin and then all sudden the DOJ the
United States government all these
people in Washington profess to love
technology and you know novelty a
Bitcoin they're gonna change their mind
number two and a lot of little old
ladies lose their money you know because
the speculative vehicle was allowed to
exist by the United States government
you know and they're gonna lose their
money and they're gonna be pounding you
should have done something about it
and number three is the most important
government whenever a government forms
itself and you go to any country in the
world
pull out the currency look at the date
that's fiat currency was formed by that
government with the central bank because
governments like to control their
currency like to know who has it where
it's going why it's going when it went
to etc and right now bitcoins a novelty
it's a hundred billion dollars you know
and a billion dollars a date raise hands
obviously mostly speculation okay and
obviously there's a real use case I'm
not make it as a joke Venezuela Cuba
North Korea criminal drug money that'll
always be true so always have a use case
that's valuable to someone because it's
better in those countries to do some you
know to have that then ask that currency
or carat or money in a bank because the
government they take that too and if you
go to Argentina you they had to affect
the savings accounts the government just
went in and took it they just took it
and you know of course everyone took the
money out of a bank or after that and in
the country basically collapsed but so
that's the reason why it's gonna get
bigger and bigger and the government to
control her and it's not the same as a
fiat currency a fiat currency the
government says you must take this as
legal tender and at par effectively cash
at par you know and it's always worth
par and I don't know why a crypto dollar
would ever be something that you know a
store value be worse than a crypto
Bitcoin so you know it's my view and I I
may be wrong and which I doubt
I've been wrong before those and if I'm
wrong I also don't care very much to it
it'll never affect my life it's not
because they write or the bankers are
defending their stuffed absolutely
untrue
you know if the Bitcoin works and we
have to do something Bitcoin will do
that to him kind of a win-win there JP
Morgan's a big investor in blockchain
technology as distinct from Bitcoin what
do you think the most interesting
applications of blockchain are going to
be final blockchain they think of is
it's it's not like a faster chip or you
know the NVIDIA GPUs and stuff like that
because when you get certain
technologies they just filter through
the whole system and they allow you to
do things differently everywhere like
just more data base and you know more
reading different natural language
processing this you basically have to
write code to have a use case for
Bitcoin so think of is it'll be deployed
use case by use case so we're using it
to move money inside the bank something
like 30 or 40 percent of the secret
Orion dollars we move is just between
JPMorgan Chase accounts okay I saw Mary
here you know from General Motors to one
of your vendors and we have both the
accounts we just move it between our own
accounts you know basically with loans
like a loan you know the loan document
dude a trade all the paperwork all the
detail no limitation all the you know
the covenants and all that could be kept
in a place where you all have the same
files all kept up to date you know who
owns you know who doesn't own it now so
that'll be one equity trading I don't
know the Bitcoin takes 10 minutes to
finish you know we do thousands and
thousands of trades split seconds
equities so it may be too late to use
for equity train it may be okay for end
of day settlement stuff so I'll just use
case by use case you can go through one
by one and say I work here it may not
work there and but the again you got to
kind of write the code we are
effectively rewrite the code so we move
from one hot topic to another you a part
of president Trump's business advisory
board should have been disbanded and
where is that dialogue with the
administration are taking place so so I
joined the council just keep in mind so
when I joined the council the president
I asked him Steve Schwarzman called up
actually and so the president like you
to join his council I am a patriot I
love the United States of America okay
and it's very you want a hell
your country and I still I'm going to
help my country so help me God
that's what I'm gonna do whether or not
you all like President Trump and and
remember we help presidents and prime
ministers all around the world I see
them we advise them we give him this and
we want to help the people of that
country to and that is part of your job
is you know as a bank and as an
individual to try to help make the world
a better place I joined the council I
did get one very long well-written
elegant nasty letter from my daughter
like basically basically how could you
dad
and my other two daughters were right to
the point ditto and my wife told me how
many of her friends she had explained it
to but remember these are all liberal
effete New Yorkers in my opinion I said
I'm a patriot doesn't mean I agree with
everything the man says or the way the
man is himself it's about trying to help
the United States of America the council
met twice so think of these council's
the truth is they aren't particularly
effective you know there I was at one I
don't know if Mary was at the second
meeting and I think the second was a lot
like the first or you know you talked
about the infrastructure you talk about
this and the president is like that's
ridiculous we get better this all true
but at one point that worth gotta be
done in detail in the agencies okay not
by a bunch of CEO sit around the table
you know telling you that you know it
takes too long to build a bridge and
this regulation hurts and we need this
in capital markets so the effectiveness
comes down over time and then after you
know Charlottesville was the last straw
but the negatives were going up you know
most of us really believe in diversity
LGBT daca programs were pro-immigrant
were you know and we certainly wouldn't
justify in any way shape or form you
know Nazism or white supremacy and stuff
like that so you know we found ourselves
having to explain to our own people by
the way because the press was always
coming up saying did you say something I
don't remember the press calling me up
and saying I have to go public
every time I disagree some Obama did so
the press really is extremely biased and
they they're gonna have to do something
about it not all I'm the old biased in
their own way but you know haven't
explained it constantly over and over
was just a negative we had a conference
called Steve Schwarzman was the chairman
he ran it we went alphabetically
everyone on the conference call said
let's just disband it there were two who
said don't having to see
table is a good thing etc etc and we
disbanded it of course
Schwartzman told the president and the
thing that came out was that the
president agreed to disband it you know
which it wasn't exactly the case but but
but but everyone in that room is still
working with the people they should be
working with to help the United States
government do proper things they need
help if you just think somehow things
decisions gonna be a property in
Washington without the help of business
they won't and so we're all doing in our
own way and obviously I do a lot with
minuchin and Cohn and you know other
people deal with the other their other
agencies etc but it's in coming up but
you try to help and you know just
because you don't like a president it's
a really bad idea
I think we've become far too knee-jerk
in our politics and and you know to me
you should be willing to help you'll
name itself yeah your name was thrown
around a lot as a potential Secretary of
Treasury that didn't happen but say you
wake up tomorrow as the secretary what
does tax reform or economic policy look
like under secretary diamond yeah so I
don't want to be Secretary of Treasury
but but we we have you know I tell
people this is important this country
has the best hand ever dealt of any
country in the planet and most people
don't fully understand it they never
make the list so I assume you have a
problem make a list and go through what
really matters and I'm gonna do this
quickly we have all the food water and
energy we need we have the Atlantic in
the Pacific which you know our founding
fathers realized how powerful it was to
defend this country from Wars and Asia
wars in Europe we have the best military
the world's ever seen that's to be true
for a long period of time and you know I
could I say compared to China but do it
respectfully China does not have enough
food borne energy okay and its neighbors
happened to be Philippines Japan North
Korea South Korea Indonesia Vietnam
Pakistan Afghanistan India and Russia
and they've had border skirmishes or
wars with like five or six of those in
the last 40 years they are in a tough
part of the world so they those
leadership they are they saying god we
need food we need access to certain
commodities we need we but we have to
have an army just to protect ourselves
from the billions of people that
surround them that aren't that have
Nestle that happy with them so the
United States also has and I got a
business go throw my Japan Japan
pan Japan Japan Japan and now then it
was BRICS Brazil Russia India China and
it was Mexico in the mist Mexico
Indonesia South Africa Turkey but none
of them have what I'm about to say the
universities we do the rule of law like
we do low corruption like we do the
widest deepest most transparent
financial markets the world's ever seen
public and private again I'm not talking
my banks here okay and the hugely
vibrant businesses small to large and
innovation like the world's never seen
and I'm not talking about just Silicon
Valley I'm talking about you go to any
company America and believe me to get in
productivity up two percent somewhere
okay and you know we know does Brazil
have that India China okay this does
most European countries have that whole
list does Mexico have it into I mean so
people don't that's the best hand but
someone went wrong and and I do think we
left behind a huge segment of society 10
million people left the workforce but I
think they're starting to come back in
20 million people are felons of which a
large amount shouldn't be found you know
I tell people you know if you all caught
doing some of the [ __ ] you did you'd be
a felon to and and you can't get a job
after that or at least you know most
companies you not gonna get job j1 by
law for most of the jobs we we by
regulatory rules and requirements go we
have the opioid crisis we have we did
there are some I think we blame trade
and immigration technology but that's
not really the reason but we have the
sum of these Rust Belt towns we left
behind
our inner-city school kids 50% don't
graduate okay and most you didn't go to
inner-city school but 50% don't graduate
they're mostly poor the mostly
minorities in this land of opportunity
there's six million open jobs today good
jobs that you can get out of high school
Welding construction electrical coding
automotive their automotive everywhere
aviation and we're not training the kids
and you know so that's why it's also why
took on the chairman the Business
Roundtable so the question I always have
is how do you fix that stuff and in
reality I think the fix is actually
known I think the hard part is getting
through Congress but you know
competitive tax reform has to be done we
and I shocked me that my Democratic
friends nice and they say
you're gonna change wages on day one of
the tour corporate tax reform that's
their measure what happened last time
that's their measure the measure you
should have is the counterfactual had
you had competitive tax system ten years
ago there would have probably been three
trillion dollars retained here companies
and capital 5,000 companies have been
bought by foreign companies cuz it's
advantageous for them to own an American
company now so while our government
dawdled on these inversions 5,000 comers
required by foreign companies net does
the study came up by E and why that
would have been retained here let me
think of corporate headquarters and you
know we damaged ourselves and it's
permanent and that four trillion
overseas and it's four trillion
someone's been reinvested hard you know
hard equipment and plant and companies
but they're still two and a half
trillion a cash that's why it's there as
not because these come here immoral it's
because it's so much more advantageous
to stuff over there Microsoft built a
research center in Vancouver because
they can't hire the same kids in Seattle
because of our immigration laws and so
you know these things have held back
America and I am absolutely convinced
and these it's hard to prove it we kept
in a model we're going to 2% in spite of
the dumb things government's done for 10
years and have we done the right thing
is on competitive taxes infrastructure
education we'd be growing to 3 percent
or more this recovery the growth is half
of a normal recovery a small business
formation is we're damn net of millions
of small companies that normally would
have been formed and the reason is lack
of access to credit regulations and
again I can't prove it I'm trying I'm
not using big data every now to try to
get some of stuff looking backwards and
that's what so the part of the agenda
the Trump administrators the right stuff
infrastructure education competitive tax
reform proper it proper regulation and I
just say proper as opposed to less or
more you know they they massive overdid
it you've heard people say that it
didn't hold back lending okay and we did
some this was really real analysis and
done by economists not by me mortgages
alone we believe it held back by one to
two trillion dollars because of the cost
lack of securitization lack of servicing
requirements and and because the
litigation stuff around it that people
are mostly the mortgage under eyes are
unwilling to make mortgage
is to first-time buyers young people
immigrants prior defaults and
self-employed not going back to the
sub-prime of the old age just open up
the credit box a little bit okay two
trillion dollars in mortgages would have
been trying 5% growth in GDP that one
thing and yet they say it didn't hold
back lending and buy that would have not
changed any risk at all for banks we
don't the most part we don't keep that
stuff and it wouldn't have changed the
risk for the government or they actually
I think the risk is lower when the
economy stronger and so that's why
that's what they should be doing I think
they are going to do so much stuff I
hope under your management JP Morgan's
gone from strength to strength but one
one instance stands out as a negative
during your tenure so the in 2012 a
london-based trader lost over six
billion dollars for the bank are there
any lessons for us all and how you dealt
with that incident and do you wish you'd
done anything differently you know
here's an example I mean this is what
our countries come to okay we we had a
record profit that year we're a big
company hugely embarrassing I'll tell
you about that mistake in a second no
customers were involved okay it was
originally put on as a hedge that
obviously didn't work okay and yet we
were punished severely in Congress two
billion dollars of fines
I mean it's outrageous it's just
outrageous that a company makes a
mistake my shirt got hurt by six billion
I hurt my shows I apologize my shows and
the government finds me two billion
addition to that because they can
because they said it's another example
of a bank being mismanaged etc no [ __ ]
happens and and it was it was it was we
had put on a hedge that was supposed to
earn a lot of money in a recession and
basically break even a normal thing and
lose money in a booming environment
think of the thing is we were short high
yields and long investigating like that
and it wasn't a complex derivatives it
mattered because the fact is that wasn't
the mistake the mistake was when we when
we put this thing on I thought and I'm
again I blame myself and I went public
right away
big mistake two billion could be a lot
worse bad strategy Bailey vetted Billy
monitored barely done my fault I'm sorry
we're gonna fix it you know and you know
the details in some ways didn't matter
but but we do G liquid
go fit in trading by the way when I had
asked them to reduce the positions in
half I had asked I had looked at some
very simple numbers of risk weighted
assets I should have asked a couple more
questions they couldn't do it so instead
of like reduce it in half and saying we
have a problem but if they said at that
point in time we were lost five hundred
million you probably won't even know
about it
but instead of that they kind of doubled
down they try to come to these old
cockamamie ways to reduce the risk but
they just added more more illiquid
positions on top of other liquid
positions and when you try to unwind
that thing that's how you get killed and
so but the lesson there's no lesson to
me I knew the second it happened I've
seen it before I got the whole
management team again all the PR people
I said guys they're gonna come after us
[ __ ] we're gonna say Jamie was like
everybody else you know big banks are
too big to manage Jamie diamonds of
failure just like these other guys he's
off his highly holy [ __ ] diamonds do
break diamond in the rough I wrote all
the headlines I said I said forget all
that stuff we're here to serve companies
serve clients we're gonna do our jobs
and hopefully the attack by the and when
that something like that happens and a
lot of you been through this that is a
letter to Evie AG to every newspaper
tabby senator to every congressman and
they'll attack like like literally like
a bunch of barking hyenas and and and
yet we all look at it like that's okay
it's not okay it's not the way
professionals people should act when
companies have problems and stuff like
that so you know there's so the fact is
there was no great lesson learned other
than for all of you whenever you have a
problem and I'd say now Zuckerberg got
one that's what he's gonna deal with I
don't not sure he completely understands
that every AG every senator every
congressman they'll turn immediately the
go on the attack they'll take advantage
of it I mean I'm surprised not talk
about finding them billions of dollars
yet and so you know that and that's what
societies you just have to learn how to
deal with that stuff so uh and the and
the the biggest risk of all the the risk
committee so we obviously bear risk all
around the world that Risk Committee
which was meeting how a senior risk
officer are when I asked what what about
this trade they said oh no that trade
was done pretty much between the the
bunch of those traders who are doing it
and I knew Drew was our CIO who I
respect they didn't want a they didn't
want to share the risk committee
that should never happen ever ever ever
ever
the arbors committee see everything my
general council sees everything my
header of compliancy is everything once
someone ever says well that we're gonna
do over here you've got a problem then
and that tends to create a issue they
will come back and want you to explore
leadership in tough situations some more
the Harvey Weinstein story is very much
in people's minds at the moment as a
leader what you feel is your role to
play in creating a work culture that's
very respectful of women well I think it
is your role to do that and you know and
something said to me up that heart of
mine says oh this well you know Wall
Street's been that way
Wall Street's not that way today folks
not not like that stuff I mean I'm sure
that maybe harassment somewhere in
JPMorgan but if you think it's condoned
by anyone to company a senior position
absolutely not okay and and we've got
you know strict processes in place to to
look at what people do and how they do
it and review it and if it involved me
in any way shape or form it would go
directly to a separate board thing it
wouldn't be like I you know I can go
negotiate a sell my own or something
like that so the first thing to
[Music]
diversity and I think it's more
important than anything else is that
everyone the company is treated the
trust and respect any meeting you walk
in you feel like you're welcome anyone
can speak up it's not a guys and you see
you know you see the subtle guys thing
I've seen this I've seen your banker
once told me Jamie watch this man who
runs a big part of coming walk into the
partners room and I walk up to you a
buddy house like that football game you
a man why would you score in golf and he
won't even talk to the women that room
you know if you're managing a group of
people and I saw you do that you'd get
an earful from me you got to talk to
everyone you can like some people more
than others we got to talk to everyone
and you have to go out of your way to
get the quiet person the reserved person
the person who you know doesn't want to
be embarrassed to get them to speak up
feel comfortable and when you have an
environment of trust and respect people
can shine okay now you should have
specialized programs and all that and
I'm for those but they don't work if you
don't create that environment it doesn't
matter and you know and I you know you
just like you would advise my three I've
three daughters if they were in a tub
environment i'ma leave go find a place
that appreciates your skills you know
and and so it will hurt a company
ultimately because you know if I get to
pick my team from
all people not just white men I would
pick a far better team I should point
out that JPMorgan Chase I'm again the
press doesn't write this half of my
direct reports or women did you hear
what I just said every article even in
the Wall Street Journal is always saying
it'll be 30 years before women represent
30% of the executive suite on Wall
Street 50% including the head of tech
now you know Laurie beer who's been
doing a great job didn't do it a couple
months and 20% of my direct reports LGBT
because they're good you know and and
30% of all the top 200 people in the
company are women and they run major
parts of the company credit card private
banking global equity capital markets an
Indian woman is ahead of us MA and that
was the most macho belt-and-suspenders
smoking cigar in the back room of all
the jobs you know and and her father
didn't even want her to go to school
college and she's actually from India
she's not she's Indian and so so yeah I
think if you do it right you'll have a
great environment for everybody and you
got to have your eyes open to it you
know what I always worry about is not is
you know we have 5000 branches and you
know I just always know that in that
branch that guy a woman but mostly the
guy who could be a bully and get away
with it because we can't see it and no
matter what we say the people in that
branch filled the hole they need their
job and they put up with it like another
one you shouldn't allow like and if
you've been I've show you better come
easy you should never allow and it came
to my attention you were not allowed to
have a golf event and invite the men in
the division and not the women it's not
allowed I mean my first inclination be
to Firestone on the spot if I heard
about that
I just just what what and don't have
golf do something different no and and
you know go out of your way to make
everyone feel accepted and you'll build
a great company
one question we often ask female CEOs
here is how they manage work-life
balance we rarely ask male CEOs but I've
heard a story that you want starting to
quit the first job because a partner
forced you to work over the weekend
unnecessarily we're not suggesting that
JPMorgan invest in banking analysts stop
doing the same but do you have any tips
for us on structuring our time balancing
demands made
anyway when I was an analyst of this
consulting company this consultant and
said you got to do this work I need it
Monday morning 9 o'clock he gave it the
assignment Friday which would all the
people in Wall Street complain about the
kids are right the MDS they come in
partners and as they they're not
thinking about the fry and then Fridays
I need this I need a Monday which mean
you gotta work all weekend and most the
time you could have done the assignment
on Tuesday and so we've actually try to
institute some policies that you can't
get people assignments and Friday
basically anymore unless it's approved
by someone senior and but he I worked
all weekend and then I show up at nine
o'clock and there's a lot I was in the
library you know research and stuff like
that and he wasn't there and he called
in at 12 o'clock or one o'clock he said
Robin I worked all weekend you said nine
o'clock it was critical he said he said
I didn't really need it until tomorrow I
just want to make sure you got it done
to which I was like and I told him I'll
never work for you again
no but there's not advice my my advice
would be a temper is not a good thing
but I and they said well if you you
can't tell the consulting firm we're
gonna work for I suggest I can cuz they
could fire me I was quite serious I
never worked for the person again and I
think that was a bully thing you know
just and that was my instinct that was
just bullying me and it was completely
unnecessary now and he knew me well
enough to know that it's gonna get done
what I told her I'd get done and stuff
like that
you couldn't have work-life balance I
tell people Jamie Moore chase it is your
job to tell your mind your body your
spirit you saw your friends your family
your health your job it's not our job so
I think there's a little bit of
misunderstanding that some of the
companies now we should do everything we
can to help you
I tell people we give you medical
shrinks Pilates massages I mean we we
really do try to take care of our people
but I can't make up for your not doing
those other things and you really have
to do it yourself most people don't work
very smart so first off it work smart
and I deal with emails and phone calls
generally once okay I have three types
of reading very fast fast very slow so
you know it's I'm and they're very slow
is too complex I really need to think
about the very fast might be a magazine
that's once you're done interested in
there or something like that and you
know you people don't run their lives
efficiently and I'm sure you've seen
even
in school here you know the people
frenzy they're always frenzied they're
late they can't get back sorry and get
back to you I couldn't get it done I got
my cases I couldn't do this if your
frenzied it's you it's not the school
it's not the job it's you because lot of
us aren't frenzied I'm I'm not I'm never
late almost never late I'm not frenzied
I have a nice flop list I know exactly
people doing I schedule time you know
for myself exercise and for you know
making my phone calls and if I didn't do
it this morning I'd be a little I would
feel harried if I did wasn't all caught
up you know and so work really smart
learn how to work smart and then in
parts you lie I think it's really
difficult when you have children that
does burn the candle at both ends
my advice to men is you better drop
watching every football game and playing
golf on both Saturday and Sunday you
know do some of your kids okay if you
don't it's neglect okay you call
whatever you want but I have a lot of
Reggie to complain about they couldn't
they have enough family time but they go
play golf on Saturday something I'm
playing golf and Saturday means you wake
up at 7 or 8 you go play golf for three
hours you have lunch use your Bloody
Mary you go home and take a nap okay and
you go to dinner with friends you know
you should have done some of your family
and so so you can do it if you're a
woman I think it's even harder you know
and I think there's some jobs are really
conducive to helping you and some aren't
you know and you got to think that
through a little bit and one of the
greatest be Tyra sort of women get was
you have it all you just can't have it
all at the same time and just be a
little thoughtful how you manage your
life that could be a man who's got to
stay home to take care of kids or sick
parents or something like that and so
it's a long race and you can pretty much
do it all but you you got to make sure
you save time for yourself to do those
things and even the toughest job you can
do that Jamie in 2014 you continued to
actively leave JPMorgan despite battling
and defeating throat cancer many people
were incredibly impressed by your
decision to stay at the helm with a
company during that time what continues
to motivate you under those
circumstances well yeah numbers not up
to me to stay home with the company and
you're never quite over with cancer
either so I'm you know I first I had to
go public with it wasn't my preference
but you know I couldn't be seen walking
in and out of
Sloane Caterine and of course I was
gonna lose weight and I didn't lose my
hair but I could have and all that and
so I just went completely clean I did go
to work like almost every day but it
doesn't that does not mean I work every
day I mean I was taking four or five
naps I lost like 40 pounds I and I
didn't want to get close to anyone
because your immune system is virtually
gone so I do you want to even get a cold
at that point but you know I said why
don't you guys so I was sitting home and
and I go I go get my treatment every
morning radiation and I go home I would
try to exercise I went from running five
miles to walking five to like literally
walking for a minute going in the floor
I was gonna pass out and walk in a
minute but it made me feel better but
the same air in the gym and then I go
but if I stayed at home you know what
you know I was doing I couldn't read it
just I thought I could read eight hours
a day I just couldn't do it but I was
staying home I was watching Isis and
Ebola and and when I go to the office
I'm surrounded by friends and
interesting things and you catch your
mind oh I had some meetings you know I
and so I just it just was better for me
and you know the board was fully briefed
the whole time and I have an
unbelievable man team and they were
great and my family is great and so that
you know was a it was an in some ways a
heartwarming experience other the fact
that's terrifying
Jimmy thank you so much thinking I will
turn it over to the audience for Q&A
thank you so much for being here mr.
diamond at what level do you think
Bitcoin has to get to before before
JPMorgan would embrace it and at what
level of demand you said there is a
level and I'm wondering what that would
be is we look today at the price of
$7,000 I doubt we're gonna embrace it at
any price so I mean to me it's that I'm
worried about being caught up in this
maelstrom of you know people losing
money and stuff like that there's no
reason for us to do any bit coin now if
you know if you're a client and you want
to get traded on the seeing me or
something like that I advise you not to
do it but you should we do it and put in
trades for client who asked us to is
sophisticated and obviously not bright
but sophisticated maybe I don't know I'm
yeah I mean I told the team
senior team I don't tell them what to do
I told because I sent a note to Daniel
Pinto runs I said Daniel I know you
heard what I said it's your job to
figure out what to do you know and if
you disagree with me that's completely
fine I'll probably do whatever he wants
in spite of what I said hi hello hi
thanks for coming a one thing I'm Puneet
I'm a second year MBA one a couple
things you said that were quite
interesting were like there's no lesson
to be learned and I don't care if I'm
wrong and I guess from a lot of senior
leaders I've noticed that self-awareness
and learning from mistakes are key
characteristics do you agree and if so
do you have an example of a time when
you've actually tried to build those
yeah so I said I didn't mention the
mistakes I made I should have asked some
more questions I bite there's one
question sort of I would have known just
one there was the one where I said it
was a tempest in a teapot I had been
tied to a stack uestion I got the wrong
answer was how liquid of the positions
how many dates can you get out I've told
ten yeah it was like hundreds and the
second I heard that I said oh [ __ ] we
have a real problem so you learned and I
actually wrote about my Chairman's lover
I said lessons learned or re learned I
knew that you know it's all you kind of
learn sometimes you learn the same
lessons over no it's like being the
boxing ring they say doc you know hold
the hands up yeah well that's harder to
do than you think but but uh yeah so you
do learn you do get better as you get
older and management and people and
decision making but the bit I'll tell
you what the biggest mistakes I've made
are they're not the specific one like
the London whale but but more the
patterns around tempers a bad idea any
decision mana temper even treating
people temper you you know you you there
always be careful why you walk in what's
Moody's he in and stuff like that you
don't get the best out of people and
sometimes only my life people said well
you know he's a well-placed blow of
anger no it wasn't it was you're just a
welling up of anger and you usually
clouded your judgment as opposed to so I
knew I had fine matured when about ten
years ago someone said in front of me
talking about something that was about
investment banker comp and I was getting
so mad and I said you know what I'm
gonna leave the room you guys stay here
for ten minute
I'm gonna come back I went out I thought
about what made me mad I came back I
told him very politely how offensive
what they were saying was to me etc etc
and but other mistakes when you don't
get the right people involved plain and
simple
a lot of answers sometimes the answer is
waiting to be found you just got to get
the people who work it may consume
you're tired make a decision on Friday
not 30 eventing people the biggest
mistakes you make up people mistakes I'd
make plenty the people mistakes it
really set back in organization because
it takes a long time to figure it out
and a lot of damage get done then you
have to replace them so it's like a year
and a half a person mistakes a year and
a half of setting the company back and
you may lose good people in the mean
time because when you put a person that
job they often Drive HUD some other good
people by the time you figure out you
made a mistake and you can avoid that
because I don't know your name but I can
get the whole book and you and never
meet you okay I can find out how smart
you are how you treat people how you
treat your friends bosses peers
subordinates whether you're on time with
you show up with the people trust you
whether you shave the truth I get that
hold dossier on you so we're pretty good
now making sure we put people these big
jobs that we know they're pretty good we
still can make a mistake but we you'd be
surprised the error rate is just
dramatically less than ever was before
hello hi I'm a 20-18 Sloan fellow I was
working for JPMorgan in London up until
March of this year and I'm just
wondering where do you see the future of
European financial services and
particularly JPMorgan in the context of
brexit yeah so Briggs it I mean the fact
is we're gonna be served we're to be
prepared for hard brexit not because
we're predicting it though I think it's
okay I think it is pretty likely at this
point I think it's a very complex thing
it's not great for Britain but the fact
is to be prepared all we have to do is
have our European subsidiaries get more
capital certain licenses certain
approvals which we're going to get so
that if if you know hard the hard brexit
it defaults the next day to existing EU
law under existing EU law we simply have
to do certain things contractually
in sovereign and in a entity that's in
the in the EU and we have them we've got
you know licenses proper sub-series and
in Germany Ireland Brussels it's
about four or five hundred jobs so it's
not that big a deal but for the but in
reality 12,000 people are serviced in
Europe out of London even after a hard
brexit and the real issue is what
happens to those 12,000 in the ten years
after because I know it's gonna happen
regulators and politician and walk and
say we're uncomfortable we know you did
the license and you book the trade in
this subsidiary but then you back to
back that to that subsidiaries to risk
manage it or you have the bank or do the
ECM deal here but the research risk
compliance audit trading was all done in
London and that's not sufficient we
don't want to pretend can Villa type of
business you got to move it here I think
there's gonna be huge pressure to move
those 12,000 people over time into the
EU and you know my goal is to make sure
we can serve our clients non-stop it'll
cost us more money it's a real pain in
the ass but that's not the point I'm not
worried about I want to build serve
those European clients we and we bank
every European country just about every
big European institution every big
European investor that's what I got to
worry about being prepared to do that
on the next day thank you this is a
continuation of what you're talking
about but what areas of the bank do you
see most exposed to technology
disruption
you mentioned sales and trading before
yeah so I first of all like I said
technology has been changing the world
forever and so it's not like it's
completely different
I think it's faster now more money's
going into FinTech you know agile
technology can do things that couldn't
be done before and I think it's
incumbent upon any business to use
technology to a better job force client
better could be better faster cheaper
straight through processing obviously
making a digital mobile stuff like that
remember banks have been doing that for
years and you can buy and sell FX on our
on your mobile phone now and when some
trade some trader did a 40 million
dollar trade and I said oh god you know
40 million dollars on a mobile phone I
said we got to put breathalyzers on
those phones I just envisioned you know
some macho trader you know having two
martinis and saying I'm gonna do this
invite you know what they mention that
to the risk people they said we do have
that and we can actually put that in so
that you can't do a trade without a
breathalyzer or something like anyway
so I think in some ways always look at a
business from the standpoint of the
clients
so forget JPMorgan so a lot of the
things that clients need they're still
gonna need in fact those needing to grow
over time
okay ECM will still be there decent
would be still there hedging FX and
hedging interest rates will still be
there M&A advice will still be there but
we have to use technology to do things
better faster quicker like everybody
else and straight through and all that
kind of stuff so but if you ask me the
thing that can be most disrupted it's
going to be payments you know there are
payment systems that you're antiquated
they're all the ACH system is terrible
but we just put out a p2p you all use
venmo we just put out p2p ezel it's
real-time bank to bank it's safer it's
better it's real-time it's not social
yet so I don't possibly know Stan why
you'd want to see all that stuff with
your friends but but it could be that it
could be in wholesale payments but no
but you can go on screens now move money
around the world convert to different
currencies and so we're doing it but if
you ask me that's where most of the
troubles gonna take place and where we
we've invested in a hundred FinTech
companies and we're going to compete
build by whatever it is and just an
example we're gonna have online trading
and Robo investing for our clients it's
in beta today well I'm not sure I'm
gonna roll it out we're gonna roll it
out and test it and test price and all
stuff like that but we can't allow those
things for free if we wanted to so we
know we're not we're not dead in the
water you know so when the time comes
you're gonna see us being very
aggressive to win businesses like we
always have and we rolled out it's not
being marketed we rolled out a mobile
only bank in st. Louis recently and
we're gonna test that more for
Millennials anyone else but you know
from opening the account the movie money
it's only the debit card and we're gonna
see how that works then we're to try to
modify that and then do it in all 50
states
go ahead they'll get it eventually
no hold it up John Jonathan Wallen
second year third year PhD student now
and I have a question about how you
brought up bureaucracy and
politicalization and the detriments that
does to the firm and my concern is how
do you assess the bureaucratization
within JP Morgan compare it with your
peers and how do you trade off the
agency that you give to individual
portfolio man
with the oversight from compliance yeah
well we're pretty rigorous how we run
the company so you know we meet all the
time and go through everything top to
bottom and we raise these issues and
stuff like that and so if you're you
know what your authorities are if you're
a traitor if you're a bank you know
exactly they also know he's not supposed
to do and you also when you go to a
compliance committee or risk committee
and under Ryan creating a credit
committee there's no mystery to any of
that and we in happens every day we've
barely make mistakes the problem and I'm
not gonna stand behind regulatory things
and we have thousands and your rules and
regular requirements and that does
create some of the bureaucracy but it's
not an excuse for us to say this is a
better way to do it we listen to
customers all the time and you know the
management team is open every issue the
gen is always set by them so it's like
you walk in the room and I said the
agenda if you work for me I expect you
to raise everything important everything
and anything including bureaucracies
cause slow down bad service competitors
got some better than us that's your job
not my job and so and that's what I do
with you hope presume you're gonna do it
your management team so you're always
airing all these issues we go on bus
trips we go to call center to go to ops
centers we've got client reviews we got
advisory groups and all those things get
circulated all of them you know and so
all the complaints we're always trying
to deal with that and become better and
faster you know I think one of the tough
thing about management is you have to
get rid of the bad people you know so I
could say anything I want but if I have
a bunch of goombazz or they're not that
good or their friends Jamie type of
thing that is what causes the problem
and so very often you have people who
were unwilling to get rid of the bad
people bad could because their cultures
bad it also could because they're not
good you know they're not good enough
you know so in a meritocracy people say
you know Joe deserves the job or good
old Joe and spin here a long time and
that doesn't mean they deserve the job
and you know in sports you know if
you're not batting 250 and I could be
playing second base you know and it's
very easy to take out a pitchers not
doing a good job in business they're
left those jobs for a long time I'm not
saying treat them disrespectfully now if
you treat people disrespectfully you
know you're gonna lose their hearts and
minds too so it's got to be a very
respectful we're gonna make a change for
the following reasons but you really
gonna run a real meritocracy you've got
to make sure you really do it and
people you know that God should filter
through the whole company - loyalty is
such a missing sometimes they usually
mean is I was asked by was a young CEO
in a room like this we had just done a
big deal how can we loyal to you when
you weren't Laurel to Joe he's been
around you trained a lot of people in
the room and you just demoted him I
couldn't answer the question and I
called the person the next day and I
answer every question eventually by the
way but I called the next day and said I
thought about it and you got it
backwards if I was loyal to Joe and kept
him the job and most people thought he
just wasn't doing a good job anymore
Who am I being disloyal to everybody
else and the customer and so it's a hard
thing to do but it and that's the
hardest thing to do but in management
right there and a lot of you will fail
doing it because you'll you're the other
thing that happens in management your
own by the staff down the hall you know
and they all take care of it don't worry
about take care basically their that
becomes a club and they're not taking
care of it for the company the clients
are taking care of it generally for
themselves and so it'd be very very
careful in management but what you why
you're doing what you're doing and who
gets to speak up and who's in the room
and things like that you go time for one
more question so I work for JPMorgan
Chase back into the other twelve part of
the team that really designed the choice
calm so I dunno like Chase is always
more towards the technically advanced
company and this question is more toward
the tech side it's like what is the
stand of backing community in a I like
artificial intelligence like AI is going
to take our automation stuffs and what
does banking community thinks about it
well I don't care thank you for think so
try to think big data a I machine
learning chat boxes robots they're all
real you know we have thousands of data
scientists and PhDs and and not just
coding and we spend nine billion dollars
in technology seven hundred million
dollars in cyber probably a billion
dollars a year now and just some of the
stuff is just uniquely devoted to that
and it's real it's an amazing thing that
you can do you can do today in split
second so we used to like you just when
you swipe that credit card you know it
goes through hundreds maybe a thousand
algorithms to test for fraud where you
did it how you did it with time we do
the same thing for big payments so if
you run a company small bit of large
company like what happened to the
Federal Reserve never had to us you know
payments the wrong time different type
different entry we're actually
monitoring your systems all the time and
we see anything wrong we're calling you
up and stuff like that so it's real the
hardest part about it isn't
understanding it or knowing the
technology it's getting the people in
the company to understand the power of
it so when we first started Big Data we
put and we big data machine and we put
it up at the central for standards and
you know we used to do but to make sure
that you don't end up with 84 different
platforms and stuff like that out of
control and machine learning has to it
has another problem with regulations
there won't go through but we put at the
top and we had to say to you hey you do
prospecting how do you do it why do you
do it
we made prospecting 10 times more
efficient the commercial bank 10 times
don't and don't think that ok the cost
is lower now instead of $30,000 of 3,000
it also means we could put two more
bankers and grand rapids I mean it's a
huge benefit to the company and be
immediately productive as opposed to
take three years to build it up and and
then once we did that we now have it in
every division and so every division has
a big data AI machine learning thing and
every we ask every manager come back and
give us the use case you think is the
best for you and so we're trying to buy
the demand is going up like this but one
of the areas you want the demand you
know you want to spend more money and
obviously once been and wisely but we
push people's own technology I would do
that
you can't ever say to me you didn't do
it because of the budget or you couldn't
afford it it's not allowed you have to
put it in your budget so in a reflection
of a 12 months of a plan I tell you have
to put in that plan everything you need
to do of growing the sales for us going
company is going technology and don't be
a baby bad because pills they why we
didn't do it we couldn't afford it this
year who said we could afford it
anything we want we spent fifty eight
billion dollars a year we make 35
billion pre-tax have you guys been on
the two billion dollars to get big data
right we're gonna do it so it's more but
it's more about the Guinean executors
right than is about the money everyone
please join me in thanking Jimmy Dean
thank you very much
[Music]